happy Friday you guys I think I'm live I
think we're live sorry for the technical
delay here we're 30 minutes behind
schedule
but today's Friday we're gonna be doing
another episode of logotherapy we're
gonna be talking to two designers two
logos today that's what we're doing it's
two by two and first up our returning
champion I'm just saying returning
champion but they're all champions
really it smart
he's with studio op Mars and he's from
the Netherlands and this is some of his
work you guys make sure if you guys like
this work go look them up and check them
out and if you've got a good opportunity
and you need an expert logo designer
consider hiring him next up also is
Everton and he's from Brazil and this is
some of his work here it's beautiful
work guys we're actually working with
him on a little something here so all
right without further ado we're gonna
jump in we're gonna to look at oh this
work I can't see it Steffen headies
Hedda bees were from Denmark is that
right yeah yep okay so take it away Mart
all right so I took this logo into
Photoshop to start sketching as always
to anybody like sketching a freehand
just to try out some different
variations of the typography so I'm just
recreating the 81m at the moment just
trying out a couple of different font
styles and just trying out some
different stuff to see what kind of
shapes work together well so it's a
video production company and one thing I
started noticing right away is that the
shapes of the the 81m kind of look like
a camera
if you rotate it you'll see this later
so this was one of them my main concepts
behind this is I wanted to make it look
like an old-school camera because it's a
fishing company but I didn't want to
make it too obvious what I really liked
about some logos is like when it's
that's like a hidden message for example
the FedEx logo it has like the arrow in
between the D and the X but it's really
not that obvious it's only when you know
it that you will see it so that's
something I was going for here as well
just making something that's resembles a
camera but it's not too obvious so it's
not cliche so I'm just trying out
different photography styles here and
just making really quick sketches trying
out
what works to get him what doesn't so
this is the first time you will see that
closely resembles a little bit the
camera oh okay yeah so I had a later
stage I'm ruling it ruling it back
because I don't want to be too obvious
mm-hmm but you will see at later stage
who not also pilot to some station air
and stuff like that that you can see the
camera sometimes so it's more like a
hidden message in the in the logo mm-hmm
so these are basically just like the
freehand sketches I always do before I
get into illustrator just to get a
feeling of typography get a feeling of
the spacing between others the the
balance between kind of the shapes and
stuff like that because for me I always
work faster in Adobe Photoshop when I'm
sketching so I'm just really recreating
every step really quickly here and once
I have something that I like then I turn
to illustrate it to kind of clean it up
and make it balanced and clean mm-hmm so
yeah just going through the stress
really quickly here this time I didn't
spend as much time on the sketches as I
used to before the other episodes
because this time I spend a bit more
time on the on the actual design of the
logo in Adobe Illustrator and layered I
also did some I some stationary stuff
and some some branding elements it's
fascinating to see your work process
through photoshopping you how you think
through the problem it's really cool
yeah I don't know for some reason I
noticed a lot of people that like to
work in Adobe Illustrator and just
duplicate their stuff there and then
make change there with some reason my
process just goes faster in Photoshop
and I'm just sticking to what I know so
hey use what every tool works for you
man yeah I mean I also like drawing on
paper but you know what you have to
extra step of having to scan the stuff
and then drag it into Photoshop and
because I have a Wacom tablets I can
just draw them here and as you will see
later in my process I'm a dude like
almost do the same stuff as an
illustrator but I'll just make it a bit
cleaner you know yeah they're just tools
so the problem is when you do it with
paper it's wonderful but then we can't
see your process and
you're putting a camera on top of it and
it takes so much more time because you
know using illustrator I mean using the
eraser on paper is time-consuming and
yeah after we draw everything and in
Photoshop you can simply copy and paste
and just makes really small tweaks you
know mm-hmm so why did you decide to go
with a thicker one now because I kind of
like the really simple basic shapes and
the only shapes are very used in this
this symbol are triangle square and two
circles and when you will see the
monster Braddock's of a bit at a later
stage it kind of makes sense now when
you see the whole picture so I'm using
really basic shapes and then I using the
contrast with the typography
and then you're repeating the element of
the lens of the camera as the II yeah I
kind of like once the topography has
like a little bit of resemblance with
the symbol yeah we were like really
small elements that connect them
together mm-hmm that's one issue I
usually have with people who design
really good icons and they slap a
typeface on there and I don't see the
connection between the two yeah it's
always nice to have that shared DNA and
are you thinking at this point you're
gonna leave it filled in or will you go
back to an outline version I like to
fill then hmm
so realice I haven't even tried out an
outline first maybe it will look better
I didn't know it then I didn't even try
to they didn't even think of it well
that's me maybe not an outline but
before you do it with strokes and now
you're filling in the counters of the 81
you know mm-hmm yeah I wanted to keep it
a bit a bit abstract I guess yeah
so that's what I'm doing it my dears
basically the same as I'm going to do in
Adobe Illustrator just making everything
snap to like the the greater guidelines
so that it's just balanced yeah
did you just doing it here in Photoshop
as well before I go into illustrator
sort of out I can make sure that I won't
run into you every any unexpected issues
in Illustrator mm-hmm did you think
about maybe losing that little beak or
the serif at the top of that one you
mean above the one you know though no
not the lens part but that little spur
or I don't know what the term is but the
little beak at the top of the one to the
left there the little triangular pink
shape and just making a straight
vertical stroke so that the camera reads
a little bit stronger all you might
other to the left yeah to the left I I
hadn't actually thought of that I mean
it would be an easy fix
mm-hmm because I'm looking at the weight
in the proportion because the one is
really fat while the eight is not as
wide and and also because of the
reference the film camera where I was
thinking III see it when you rotate it
to the side but it's much harder to see
when it's vertical yeah I think you like
subtle but that's one thing I was
looking at like do you need that little
triangular thing sticking out the left
shape okay so talk us through what
you're doing right now Mart I'm just
trying out some different color
variations because I used to RGB color
palette in and the main symbol mm-hmm so
I'm also making like some secondary
color variations because sometimes for
certain applications you might only be
able to use black or white or maybe just
use one color so I'm just creating some
different variations and I'm just trying
out the tagline yeah it's going mm-hmm
but I ended up going with a different
tech and I I spoke to Steven us to
Stefan about this and he doesn't use the
tagline beYOU know the blob way himself
but I just added one just to be sure
just stuff like this optional variation
of the logo with the tec-9 know it but I
ended up using the
with just the 81 media and most of my
applications mm-hmm has he seen the
finished product yet Stefan no I haven't
showed him yet okay he was excited about
seeing it so maybe I don't know if he's
tuned in or I will definitely message
message him on Facebook to show it
mm-hmm
I hope he's tuned in live I wouldn't
check right now let me see who's
watching us live
people calling you the brush god I like
that
let's not make merry yeah it is you
should just that's your new tagline yeah
good brush God
yeah the brush god yeah I mean the way
that you work in Photoshop is super
efficient like the way that most of us
would work in Illustrator well
incredible all right so now we're in
Illustrator
yeah just talking on some variations
yeah I didn't really like the balance
between the E and the rest of the
letters you felt a bit already say it's
small mm-hmm so I ended up extended it a
little bit to left to the right I see so
the width of it you may need long wider
yeah I made it a bit wider so it matches
more with the rest of the letters mm-hmm
but this is basically just repeating the
steps that I do in Photoshop just in
fact on this time and as you can see my
false little side always very messy
hideous tuned in she's saying hello
everybody oh hello so you made a pattern
there were you playing around with a
pattern yeah I was just saying I would
bet him I thought I might use a later
stage but I ended up using a different
pattern for some of the identity work
what it's like this is the same as I'd
like having these small returning shapes
in different aspects that identity you
know and he I changed a little bit
because I felt like eight looked a bit
like it was smaller than the wall mm-hmm
so I extended a little bit and also you
can see that the one has changed a
little bit there's more of a a bit
thicker yaga and wider and then you you
chopped off the point right
I extended the bit towards the bottom
mm-hmm oh I see that you've added a
triangle at the bottom of the a
just a repetition of that form huh yeah
so this is the end of the video mm-hmm
this brush which to be honest I'm still
using ideals trick to creating a project
and behinds and then getting everybody
to check it out ambiance and then so
this the project yes I actually because
we discussed this this session like two
or three weeks in advance I had a bit
more time than usual so and you spend a
bit more time on the project this time
mm-hmm
so you've just saw and usually present
my work through clients or zombie hands
show the process and show how the logo
was created I know people always like to
see this kind of stuff so I always edit
in my project yeah it's nice to see the
breakdown and to see the evolution of a
mark - so this is cool that you guys are
going to be posting it live on Behance
so that when the people see this video
they can also go and check out the
behavior page which is really cool this
is basically the same stuff little I
also had in my illustrator file just a
color variation saying this is a
slightly different pattern I have some
space between it because it looks a bit
more easy on the eyes yeah I like this a
lot better at like school oh and I like
these little elements that you kind of
explode it all over the page yeah so
this I'm just in both better than these
exploded fuse a little bit mm-hmm on the
business cards for example I like more
when it was just the symbol in the
middle with the elements around it and
then the really clean one nicely this is
a pattern for the back side of the
letterhead
is that what that is yeah this is more
like what he calls like a briefcase
where you could put your pipes inside
like a folder yeah yeah I see so this is
one of those examples where you can
actually see when you rotated a bit but
you can actually see that the camera
whether mm-hmm so yeah doubles it nice
good job man and thanks for your
patience and your persistence because we
had so many problems see the three piece
Oh anyway so
well I'm sure Jonah it needs to change
his shirt later because he's probably
went up a storm right now
have no idea make sure you use that
underarm deodorant okay 112 people
watching this live I think there were
some issues with notifications people
didn't know about this but we tried to
post this on Facebook if you guys are
following along with the program you
know that we do these periodically and
we do try our best to let you guys know
short of sending you an email and
bothering everybody but please make sure
you tuned in to the Facebook because
that's when we're posting the time and
the schedule of all that okay having
said that let's get back into it and
let's see who was up next we're gonna
talk to Everton now and he's going to be
taking on Sean Browns logo for Colorado
for a he's from Colorado Springs and
it's for the gas shop are you gonna have
to this or not he's juggling many things
but this is for Sean Brown and he's from
Colorado Springs and this is his logo
that's for the gas shop
okay so Everton's gonna join us shortly
once we switch hosts here yes Jared
screen real quick okay share screen
meanwhile look at this and if you guys
are having a sense of FOMO fear of
missing out make sure you guys follow us
on Facebook because this is where we'll
post calls for submissions and we
started a new thread and when we say hey
what are your logos send them on in and
then people send them in and then our
logo therapist quote-unquote will then
pick somebody that they feel like they
could do something with it
and it's always interesting for me to
see what logos people choose alright
okay are you ready yes so everything
you're up man all right can you hear me
yes I've been clear nice a good job mark
rush God so I guess we were going to
talk about basic shapes today so this is
guest shop the name stands for graphics
and science I talked a little bit with
with Sean about it and explain to me a
little bit though they are a
multi-disciplinary studio that focus on
business consultant' as their long-term
goal but they offer design solutions to
solve this this
you know your clients problems and this
this design solutions can vary a lot
like a more efficient website your
rising company logo to your graphic
signage on a facade and the reason the
this is the current logo so the reason
that the logo is the way is just because
they love that kind of old-school guest
shop environment you know mm-hmm like
that old-school typography in both both
colors bolder retro yeah a little retro
and and I mean I don't haven't much to
say about this logo the way it is now
because you know everyone is on a level
and you know like it's all good so I try
to get myself to a little research from
this kind of marks here mobile shell how
can I pronounce that this one here
Texaco Texaco right yeah okay
here in Brazil call - a co2 shot go like
that that sounds more interesting kind
different yeah I mean I like to be here
man every time I've been here I learned
something new so it's great so you know
you have this super basic shapes nice
colors vibrant colors they are playful
colorful they're made to be seen from
from distance right then they mentioned
to me like they liked like those 70s
kind of stripes Feige it has kind of
thing you know like basic shapes and he
talked to me about Aaron traveling -
yeah I mean everyone knows him right and
about some of his work too you know so I
ended up like okay like how can i how
can I do this
the most simple way you know way so this
time I started like instead throw
doing the whole logo on the trash or
something like I just went and tried to
set set down a little bit you know stir
it to it and try to understand really
what the logo could the current logo
could talk to me something about it you
know I mean I can try to save something
out of it you know and I was trying to
this kind of really semi circles like a
corner I was already thinking about the
stripes like to give that Kodak and IBM
kind of feeling you know hmm but I ended
up like being this kind of form here
this shape and it's super simple you
know try to reduce like the minimal G
that I could I could find out so I went
to illustrator and then I mean I didn't
share a video because it's so simple so
simple it's a rectangle right and you
just run the corner centers I was trying
to keep that on on this level for this
project so and when I came to this
scream yeah I kind of remember an
interview a video that rappeling talks
about the way for could help behold
something inside you know and I just
want to share here with you guys the the
YouTube videos for tips to make weird
symbols from directly mm-hmm guys can
check it out if you don't so he talks
about forms like a holding spaces like
something inside a shape it's a safe
place for it to live because have the
sign the symmetry of the shape to guide
the entire form you know and whatever
impacts inside there it it B holds so it
will stick to it and it's a nice way to
think so I went explore like what could
I be what could I throw on this visual
language inside that simple shape right
just to try remember
ciao and also the kind of which comments
he said s so sorry guys okay yeah that's
a dangerous one too right well you know
like let's just try to test me like
these scholars maybe keep it simple you
know trying to get a point of it so but
remember rights out there they act first
like a consultant so I wasn't feeling
the right way about it and this is real
man like this is the real deal like this
is this happens all the time you reach a
certain point and maybe you have to
validate that idea feels like if it's
something it's it's good to go or door
and you have to move faster to change
change things up you know so I wasn't
sure about it and I decided to add some
little tweaks here and there so I went
to a more square shake try to modify
that G a little bit you know try to feel
more comfortable about being like a
design firm consultant and tried just
sooo to bring this idea alive and then I
was really like I was really liking that
that idea you know basic form simple
shapes you have enough illusion here
that come comes down side and goes to
the top again I thought that oh that's
that's nice that's Bo that's something
that from the seventh and then I went
and kind of flip it you know rotated and
I just got to this this idea here and oh
yeah and it's something that caught my
eyes like we have some dynamics you know
on here you know sting shapes we can bet
it
we can do whatever we can throw some
callers at it that's okay that's cool
they feels like James Brown right yeah
some funky and I'll let all that [ __ ]
and then I throw some callers a just to
kind of get the mood nice and I try to
to combine those things so okay I was
feeling that's good but you know maybe
can very very directly I would say so
maybe you can they can run some stickers
you know like to put on the notebook or
something faded paint this on the wall
it would be would appear really cool and
then okay explore a little further I
went today's dark brow kind of of
background here just trying to to see
that John Travolta nice moves or
something and okay that's cool too you
know nice contrast
I like the colors I like the way the
simple shapes works together but again I
wasn't sure like you know it's too dated
right I don't know about you guys but
it's I don't know if something like to
celebrate something I think it's cool
but you know I don't I would not deliver
this for for the final product and then
I from this point on I just always
thinking like how can i how can I bring
those ideas like from nowadays like from
today so I kind of rearrange things
maintaining the symbol as I as a part of
the brain I went a little lazy I guess
for the typography so very canoe like
safety place you know just to get things
going and to this point I would realize
the same
thing again I love you know like is the
studio the better the better way that it
could possibly be you know in and
explored a little further maybe change
it to a little bit mess with The Strokes
and so on and so forth but this feels to
me like more nowadays kind of design
firm consultant and this kind of thing
and then just to bring some colors to
eat some dynamics I did this mock-ups
here this business car mess a little bit
with the stripes like those old
cassettes VHS kind of thing just to you
know play with some forms a little bit
[Music]
and again we can explore options here
different techniques like I don't know
in English the name of it put kind of
like when there's light here kinds of
spice a little bit you know that could
be nice too but uh yeah the color black
off-white charcoal black off-white
orange very bold very vibrant some other
applications here modern design like how
could it use the symbol alone use the
gas to do like as a brain mark and
father is here to just forget this whole
modern idea on advertising and how that
could be on social media in all of that
and that's basically it
here we have the a and B can throw me to
the Lions I forgot to throw mark the
line and so we could do it here okay so
on the left is a the original one
what is GSN for something in science
this is m4 it's an acronym GA didn't you
say it's an acronym right
everton didn't he say John what what is
yes for GA s graphics and signs yeah
graphics and science guys so it's gash
up
graphics and science and they wanted a
retro look there's a cool kind of
petroleum vibe kind of oil and gas vibe
to it and that's where Everton took it
so he started to explore abstractions of
that and still kind of have that retro
vibe to it and I just want to say this I
just want to say this your lockup with
the GA s that you did I thought was
really beautiful I would put that on a
sticker and put it on something and
that's a power of a good mark like when
it looks good enough when you can slap
it on something and it makes it valuable
I know you're about whether or not it
was dated or not it has a vibe it has a
look and it when you do it on purpose
then it has a sense of nostalgia and I
think it's totally fine so I didn't have
an issue with it some people are
mentioned in our comments that it was a
little harder to read and maybe maybe
and it's okay and I think that solutions
are very very elegant so the guys let's
vote let's vote in the comments here so
let's go back to the screen a and B so a
is the original on the Left B is the
revised one in and Everson created a
symbol that's an abstraction that G and
locked it up with Helvetica gasps to do
typeset so what do you guys prefer let
us know A or B
hey Herbie okay and you guys can put
that in the comments right now so we can
tell a or B and tell us why and the why
might help us a little bit okay so
people are voting so we'll go there so
Mart does Mart have an A or B screen up
ready Mart if you do we'll cut back to
you and we can get the people to vote as
well okay so it's always interesting to
me when you give a very clear brief to
create a person and depending on who you
hire you can have a completely different
result I think that's the beauty and the
interesting thing about human beings we
often talk about the threat of
artificial intelligence and how it's
going to take over all of our jobs and
maybe it will one day but right now I'm
not that concerned because what Everton
did and what marked it for their local
interpretation
I just don't think machines are going to
be able to do they'll be able to create
a
version but not Mart's version or
Everton's version so guys yeah yeah
let's do your a and B and let's let's
cut to you hit screen if we can do that
okay people are voting right now all
right this is B okay give us one second
Jonah has to do some magic there I think
yes I'm still on Everton screen
everything can you tell did you have to
stop sharing yep so people are voting
here it's a little bit of mixed results
here let me see here now it started out
with a and then it just started to
become B all the way yeah and then
somebody Paul Alvarez is like a just
kidding he's playing around with that is
here Paul how could you do that to
people
mark can you share your screen I'm sure
I still can't see it okay same ball guys
stand by we're eventually gonna get this
thing to be very smooth it's only three
years but don't worry we're gonna
eventually get this really smooth all
right there we go all right let's see
all right on the left side on the left
side is the original 281 M mark and then
marks is on the right side and he's
incorporated as a kind of a hidden
symbol the camera because that's what
his business is about so 81 media he
wrote out the word media and that's what
he's been able to create so guys about a
four the left was which is the original
and the revised logo mark word mark
combination there that would be B so
form art what do you guys think
A or B people are saying right okay
let's see what else are gonna say it
takes a little bit for them to catch up
with us but okay so while they vote we
can just have a little conversation here
so Jonah despite our technical
difficulties we we survived this
broadcast I just wanna let you guys know
because some people have never been
unaware that we have a second YouTube
channel which is actually growing quite
nicely for us we segment our content all
the design content stays on the Academy
Channel all the mindset business
negotiation pricing role play that
exists on the main channel so that's how
we separate the two so we're doing
tutorials we're talking about design
heavy stuff we found that it's getting
really muddy
so we
moved our content over to this channel
so if you're new here welcome and if
you're not new well thanks for tuning in
and checking us out I think we're kind
of hitting that mark or we need to end
the show pretty soon I want to thank
both Mart and Everton for doing this
with us you guys they're the most
consistent people who are logo
therapists for this channel so I really
appreciate you guys thanks very much you
guys for doing this round of applause
please yeah yeah thanks very much okay
so I think Jonah cut to my screen here
we go I just want to remind everybody to
to LIKE comment and subscribe and don't
forget to ring that Bell for
notifications that's it for us we're
gonna get out of here I'm trying the
music guys have a great weekend see you
guys next time
[Music]
I know how to do that